vamos a restarle 286 a 913 primero lo
voy a hacer de una manera un poco
diferente tome cada uno de estos números
y los escribí de esta manera el 9 en la
posición de las centenas representa 900
el 1 en la posición de las decenas
representa 10 y el 3 en la posición de
las unidades representa 3 de la misma
manera el 286 es igual a 200 más 80 más
6 así que vamos a tratar de restar en
cada posición empezamos en la posición
de las unidades y tenemos un problema
inmediatamente 3 es menor que 6 como
podríamos restar un número grande de uno
pequeño y tenemos el mismo problema en
la posición de las decenas 80 es mayor
que 10 como podemos restar un número
grande de uno pequeño y tal vez ya han
pensado que la solución aquí es
reagrupar a veces se llama pedir
prestado tomar un valor del lugar y
ponerlo en otro entonces vamos a ver que
tenemos aquí
tenemos un 3 y queremos tomar un valor
de otro lado podría tomar 10 del lugar
de las decenas y entonces éste sería 0 y
si pongo este 10 en el lugar de las
unidades aquí nos quedaría 10 más 3 o
sea 13 13 y fíjense que me ha cambiado
el valor 900 + 0 + 13 sigue siendo 913
esto resuelve el problema para la
posición de las unidades ahora puedo
restarle 6 a este 13 pero el problema en
la posición de las decenas se vuelve
peor ahora tengo que restar 80 de 0 y
que hago entonces aquí tengo un valor en
el lugar de las centenas y puedo tomar
100 de este novecientos y aquí me van a
quedar 800 y puedo dar este 100 a la
posición de las decenas entonces aquí
voy a tener 100
fíjense que esto sigue siendo 900 13 800
más 100 más 13 es igual a 913 y esto
resulta muy útil porque ahora puedo
restar en cada columna un número pequeño
de un número mayor
aquí se ve un signo positivo pero estoy
restando el signo de la resta está de
este lado y estamos restando 6 de 1380
de 100 y 200 de 800 vamos a hacerlo 13
menos 67 100 menos 80 es 20 800 menos
200 es igual a 600 y el resultado de 600
más 20 más 7 lo que nos da 600 27 y
ahora vamos a hacer exactamente lo mismo
de este lado pero sin modificar la
escritura de los números aquí tenemos un
6 que es mayor que 3 y lo que podemos
hacer es reagrupar desde la posición de
las escenas
tomamos 10 de aquí y la posición de las
escenas se queda con 0 y damos esa
en la posición de las unidades entonces
una decena más tres unidades nos da
trece y lo ponemos aquí ahora tenemos un
problema con las decenas como le
restaría mos 8 a 0
bueno pues podemos tomar 100 de la
posición de las centenas así que 900 se
convierte en 800 y le damos esos 100 a
las decenas y tenemos 100 más 0 decenas
es igual a 100 y 100 es lo mismo que 10
decenas ahora estamos listos para restar
13 menos 67 10 menos 8 es 2
recuerden que realmente este 10 es 10
decenas menos ocho decenas es igual a
dos decenas como lo vimos de este lado
diez decenas menos ocho decenas es igual
a dos decenas 100 menos 85 a la 20 y
finalmente 800 menos 200 nos da 600
el resultado es 627